oui bonjour olivier flipo de l'école du
hazé
je me permets de vous appeler parce que
j'apprends à l'instant que votre enfant
était positif c'est comme ça tous les
jours pour ce directeur d'école primaire
depuis la rentrée scolaire le 3 janvier
dernier il va falloir que je fasse un
mail à tous les parents en disant trois
tests vont être contents les parents
trois auto test en une semaine c'est la
règle en france dès qu'un 4e vie d'edie
clary dans une classe c dans l enfer
déjà pour les élèves quand je rentre
dans une classe et je dis bon bah écoute
et voilà vos parents vont venir vous
chercher parce qu'il ya un cas positif
dans la classe vous avez des enfants qui
se met à pleurer la colère des
directeurs d'établissements maëlys la
partage elie confinées à la maison parce
que margot l'une de ses jumelles a
contracté lakovic 19 dans sa classe de
maternelle la jeune mère de famille est
aussi enseignante au primaire la maladie
de sa fille elle la vit plutôt bien mais
la succession des différents protocoles
sanitaires dans les écoles beaucoup
moins en une semaine ça a changé quatre
fois donc déjà c'est pas lisible ni pour
les parents ni pour les enseignants je
suis venu la dernière version des
mesures a observé dans les écoles leur a
été annoncé en direct à la télévision un
allègement des exigences pour répondre
aux vives critiques les professeurs et
des parents à bout de souffle il n'est
dorénavant plus nécessaire de passer en
pharmacie ou en laboratoire ou les temps
d'attentes vont souvent delà d'une heure
pour effectuer un premier test c'est
quelque chose qui donne une illusion qui
se passe quelque chose mais dans la
réalité c'est des gens qui vont remplir
des papiers pour faire plaisir
aux directeurs d'école nouveaux
enseignants sans faire les tests elle
est loin d'être seul dans sa profession
en avoir ras-le-bol un mouvement de
contestation inédit s'organise chez ses
collègues ce jeudi environ 75% des
enseignants et directeurs des écoles de
france feront la grève n'a demande c'est
que l'état assume ses responsabilités et
sécurisé des écoles pour que les
personnels et les enfants sont en
sécurité et un gouvernement qui affirme
que l'objectif c'est de garder les
écoles ouvertes hu se disent tout à fait
d'accord résident demande à quel point
le ministre se plaît à dire nous en
france nous sommes uniques nous ne
fermons pas les écoles les classes
fonctionnent est ce que vous pensez
réellement sérieusement qu'une classe
fonctionne quand vous avez comme lundi
par exemple deux élèves dans une classe
cette fois et c'est chose rare le
personnel scolaire peut compter sur un
appui solide de nombreux parents
d'élèves à si les gens sont pas dans la
rue il ya rien qui bouge donc faut pas
avoir le la chose à son échelle en se
disant mon voilà j'aurai une journée de
travail ça va être compliqué il faut
être solidaire de tout le monde ce
mouvement il est assez serré parce que
là en face on n'emploie plus quoi on
peut pas faire notre métier comme il
faut et mais tout va bien ils ont dicté
au rêve d'un retour aidé dans ses
paroles on entend bien l'écho du
désarroi et des appels à l'aide des
employés du secteur de la santé si marie
ève bédard radio canada